the protests against police brutality
dominated much of the news this week
rioting looting and violence grabbed
many of the headlines but out of the
smoldering anger some moments of peace
and understanding last Saturday after
protesters and police faced off
nationwide chief Andrew Mills of the
Santa Cruz California Police Department
took a different approach and that
determined in my mind that I wanted to
take a knee with the community to show
my support for our community that there
can be a peaceful way to do this without
having right here and we as a community
can do better that we as the police
department must be better in make sure
that we're not policing from a
standpoint of bias after chief Mills
statement other law enforcement officers
across the country followed when the
protesters asked me to take a knee it
was it was an easy thought it was there
was nothing hard for me to think about I
want people to know that I did it for
peace I did it for unity and I did it
for healing
there were no barriers between police
and protesters in Camden New Jersey with
officers marching in lockstep with
protesters
in Nashville where earlier in the week
City Hall have been set ablaze
demonstrators convinced National
Guardsmen to lay down their riot shields
I think the engagement that we saw in
Nashville last night gives us a glimpse
of what can be and I'm very thankful for
that
other demonstrators like Pittsburgh
protest organizer Alexander Cash have
also reached out
all the stuff that they did downtown is
really tragic I don't I want to show
that we can be peaceful what do you want
to tell your children about this moment
still the delicate tension remains as
the nation waits to see whether voices
of reason endure
we can't keep repeating our faults and
our errors because we lost too many
lives doing that